السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد مزيمز
ونستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وفي نشرتنا اسبوعان على كارثه
فيضانات ليبيا وزلزال المغرب اليوم
العالمي للغه الاشاره وهل سيفرض ماسك
رسوما على استخدام اكس اضافه الى اخبار
اخرى لنتابع معا لنبدا مع اليوم العالمي
للغه الاشاره الذي يحتفل به العالم اليوم
ويهدف لرفع مستوى الوعي والثقافه حول
الصوم الذين يتجاوز عدده هم 72 مليونا في
العالم للحديث عن هذه القضيه واهلها لن
اجد افضل من الزميل ناجي زكرنا مذيع لغه
الاشاره في الجزيره يا مرحبا استاذ ناجي
اولا اهلا وسهلا بك اخي محمد نقول بالنسبه
لهذا اليوم اللي هو اليوم العالمي للغه
الاشاره نتمنى من الله نتمنى من الله ان
المسؤولين يسمعوا كلام او اشاره الاشخاص
الصم وياخذ خذوا الحقوق الواجبه الواجب
اعطائهم اياها هذا حق وواجب
وا القوانين الدوليه اتفقت على مساعده
الصم طبعا في العالم وخاصه في العالم
العربي شكرا شكرا نحن نسعد كثيرا بمتابعه
فئه الصم والجزيره منذ انطلاقتها تقدم هذه
الخدمه الاخباريه لهذه الفئه العزيزه شكرا
جزيلا شكرا شكرا
محمد الى موضوع اخر الى ليبيا فبعد
اسبوعين على الفيضانات المدمره لا تزال
جهود الاغاثه والبحث عن مفقودين مستمره في
درنا التي دمرت السيول ربع مساحتها رغم
تضاؤل الامل بايجاد ناجين بينما ارتفعت
وتيره المنشدات طلبا لمزيد من فرق الانقاذ
والاليات والمعدات والخدمات كما نقل عشرات
العسكريين والمسعفين العاملين في المدينه
الى المستشفى بعد اصابتهم باعراض اعياء وا
اغماء في حين نزح 43 ال شخص بسبب
الفيضانات من شرق البلاد ومن ليبيا الى
المغرب حيث لا تزال جهود الاغاثه والانقاذ
مستمره جراء كارثه الزلزال في اقليم الحوز
وعن هذا ساتحدث مع زميلنا عمر الحاج الذي
وصل للتو من تغطيه الاحداث هناك يا مرحبا
عمر مرحبا محمد الحمدله سلامتك الله يحييك
ما الذي لفت انتباهك هناك يعني الحقيقه
حقه بدايه الجهود الهبه التي كانت في
المغرب كانت جهود ملحوظه الناس كانوا
ياتوا من اقاصي البلاد من طنجه من العرائش
او حتى من الداخله العيون في الجنوب على
كل المستويات المستوى الشعبي المستو
منظمات وايضا الجهود الحكوميه الموجوده
المشهوره اللي كان هناك مؤسسات سياديه
ايضا كانت موجوده لو تسالنا عن جهود
الاغاثه بسرعه استطيع القول انه الجهود
تراجعت الى حد ما مقياسا مع الايام
الماضيه وهذا امر طبيعي بعد مرور نحو
اسبوعين من الزلزال الان تركيز على
استخراج الجثث اكثر مما هو البحث عن ناجين
لان الامر تقريبا توقف ومع ذلك السلطات لم
تحدد حتى الان انهاء لعمليات البحث عنا
جينا محتملين نعم شكرا جزيلا عمر الحاج
يعطيك الف عافيه وبالتاكيد الشكر موصول
لكل فريق الجزيره الذي قدم تغطيه جميله
هناك شكرا جزيلا يعطيك الف عافيه اذا الان
الى موضوع اخر ضمن انجازنا الاسبوعي مساء
الثلاثاء الماضي اطلقت اذربيجان عمليه
عسكريه خاطفه في اقليم كارباخ استمرت نحو
24 ساعه قبل ان يتم تعليقها اثر التوصل
لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار حيث بدا
الانفصاليون الارمن تسليم اسلحتهم واعلنت
اذربيجان استعاده السياده على الاقليم
الذي بسببه خاضت مع ارمينيا حربين وفي
يريفان اندلعت احتجاجات على ما التت اليه
قضيه كارباخ وتنديدا بطريق اداره رئيس
الحكومه الارميني نيكول بشنان لهذه الازمه
في التعليق الاول تجدون فيديو يتحدث عن
كارباخ وعن تاريخ الصراع الاذربيجاني
الارميني في هذا الاقليم الى نيويورك حيث
تعقد الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده اعمال
الدوره
78 بمشاركه عدد كبير من المتحدثين من
زعماء العالم الامر الذي يعكس كثره
الازمات والصراعات في حين يغيب عن هذه
الدوره
رؤساء وقاده روسيا والصين وبريطانيا
وفرنسا كما تشهد هذه الدوره اول ظهور شخصي
للرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي في
الامم المتحده منذ بدء الحرب حول هذه
الدوره لنتصل بالدكتور عبد الحميد
صيام مرحبا دكتور ما ابرز ما ميز الدوره
78 للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده هناك بعض
الم لاحظات اولا غياب اربعه رؤساء
من الدول التي لديها عضويه دائمه في مجلس
الام كان امرا ملحوظا ثانيا حاولت الدول
الغربيه ان تعطي زخما كبيرا لزياره
زيلنسكي لهذه الدوره فاعدت له جلسه مجلس
امن على مستوى الوزراء ولكن ايضا لاحظنا
ان هذه الدوره شهدت عددا كبيرا من
الاجتماعات الجانبيه والقمم التي نستطيع
ان نسميها مهمه اكثر حتى من الدوره خاصه
قمه المناخ وقمه اهداف التنميه المستدامه
وقمه المستقبل والاجتماعات الخاصه بمحاوله
ضء الاوبئه في المستقبل وهناك اجتماعات
جانبيه حول فلسطين واليمن وليبيا والسودان
وغيرها شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور عبد الحميد
الملياردير ايون ماسك يثير الجدل مجددا اذ
صرح عن مقترح بفرض رسوم شهريه على حسابات
منص اكس وهو ما يعد التغيير الاكبر الذي
قد تشهده شبكه التواصل الاجتماعي الشهيره
منذ استحواذه عليها قبل نحو عام ماسك عرض
مقترحه المثير للجدل خلال لقائه رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو وقال
ان الرسوم الشهريه اليسيره قد تكبح جيوش
الحسابات الاليه عدد كبير من المستخدمين
والمعلنين قبلوا برد فعل سلبي فرض الموقع
رسوما جديده على الخدمات التي كانت مجانيه
سابقا لنقرا لكم بعضا من تغريداتكم بندر
يقول نلقاها من التضخم ولا من ايلون ماسك
ايه بس اما منذ فيقول اتمنى ان ياتي
مستثمر يشتري تويتر ويرجعه نفس قبل ويلغي
كل قرارات ايلون ماسك اما نجود فتقول في
البدايه اعتقدت ان هذا القرار غبي ولكن
حين ادركت ان ماسك يحاول تدمير الروبوتات
او تقصد البوتات في المنصه فكرت انه قراره
يبدو اقل غباء بالفعل شاركونا انتم ايضا
في التعليقات عن هذا الموضوع وكل المواضيع
عبر التعليقات المتاحه في ايجاز هنا
الاسبوعي الذي وصلنا الى نهايته نلتقي
بحول الله الاسبوع المقبل كنوا في
المتابعه اينما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل
[موسيقى]
خير y